immortality is a gift frequently sought
by men through the ages
stories of things like the universal
panaceas or the elixir of life magical
potions are common in the third century
explorers went out in desperate search
for the Fountain of Youth water of life
a legendary spring that will restore the
youth of anyone who drank of its waters
ensuring immortality and escaping death
forever this futile search continued for
many centuries but to no avail it seems
that no one in all these years has ever
been able to get their hands on the
magical formula the fact remains there
is no escape from death there's nothing
you can drink eat or do to invade the
stark reality of leaving this world and
going on to something else
that will capture every one of us young
old rich or poor American or African we
will all die someday so the real
question is not when or how but rather
what what will happen to you when you
die what have you done to prepare for
your death what will you say when you
meet your maker what did you spend all
your time in this life doing this world
is a short and temporary one it is no
way our final destination you attend
funerals cry over lost ones what your
wills but somehow conveniently forget
that you will someday be Six Feet Under
just like all those who have passed
before you really imagine this I want
you to visualize it to the best of your
ability when you've made it to your
grave lying in your coffin six feet
under of dark cold soil what will you be
thinking as your
family and your friends are walking away
will you be ready to answer for all that
you have done or not done in life
consider yourself on a journey a journey
that ultimately leads to that afterlife
this life is simply a short stop on that
ride your stop may last 75 years or it
may last much less some people live to
be around 100 and others don't make it
to their 18th birthday regardless of the
length of your stay you will be moving
on you're going to Train that's taking
you somewhere and that's no and there's
no way the conductor is going to forget
about you are you ready for your final
stop to meet your Creator will you be
able to answer for each and every one of
your actions or have you been cruising
along which is making the most of each
moment as though your life will never
come to an end it's time to live your
life as if you're going somewhere it's
time to actually prepare for a
successful afterlife death can come that
can take you anytime it will come to you
and to all of us knowing this how many
of us will actually be ready for it my
sincere genuine advice is take time to
find out what the purpose of life is so
that you can better prepare for the next
life a great place to start is by
seeking guidance and direction from the
Creator who created you I'd also advise
you to look into the Quran and go from
there thank you my friends caring and
sharing so like and share this video and
support the Deen show so that we could
continue educating and sharing the
message of peace peace is acquired by
submission to the will of God it's not
with the world assalamu alaikum peace be
with you